bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue dans sa
bourgade de ferrari de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir les 60 ans des accords
d'evian 18 mars 1962 cessez le feu en
algérie ouvre la voie à l'indépendance
pour évoquer ce passé qui ne passe pas
des deux côtés de la méditerranée un
historien une grande référence sur cette
période il est l'auteur d'un rapport
important sur la mémoire de la
colonisation et de la guerre d'algérie
benjamin stora est avec nous ce soir
dans notre dans des bars va s'arrêter
sur l'une des mesures les plus explosifs
du programme d' emmanuel macron dévoilé
hier le pacte aux enseignants travailler
plus pour gagner plus de nouvelles
missions en échange d'une meilleure
rémunération et puis aussi plus
d'autonomie dans le recrutement des
profs en primaire de quoi réformé en
profondeur notre école pour le meilleur
ou pour le pire ce sera dans notre face
à face sur ce plateau enfin j - 23 avant
le premier tour dans le scan ce soir le
carnet de campagne de stéphane blakowski
bien sûr twitter et les candidats vus
par la sémiologue virginie spike et puis
le clan comme du candidat matheron au
crible du politologue thierry vedel
voilà pour le menu vous savez tous ces
partis
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'être là bonsoir
benjamin stora jours c'est pas plaisir
de vous avoir en cette journée
anniversaire des accords d'evian grand
témoin ce soir historien bien sûr est
l'auteur de très très grand nombre de
livres sur la guerre d'algérie
spécialiste du maghreb contemporain
votre dernier rapport fait date sur la
question de la mémoire et de la
colonisation et de la guerre on peut
citer français algérie les passions
douloureuse chez albin michel il ya une
cérémonie je voulais vous nous en disiez
un mot vous êtes évidemment invités
demain à l'elysée est intéressant de
savoir si le président de la république
veut que toutes les mémoires liés à
cette guerre là soient représentés vous
savez donc je connais pas les détails de
la cérémonie mais effectivement je crois
qu'à
l'ensemble des représentants en deux
groupes principaux de mémoire touchés
par cette histoire pour la guerre
d'algérie c'est à dire bien sûr
principalement bon les pieds noirs les
arcs et les immigrés les algérie
indépendantiste et puis je crois aussi
que l'ambassadeur d'algérie a été invité
mais je connais pas ça l'ambassadeur
d'alger reste intéressant bonsoir alexis
corbière merci d'être avec nous est
député la france insoumise de cette
hernie on avait envie d'initier un
dialogue entre vous de ce soir puisque
vous êtes ancien prof d'histoire en
lycée on va parler du travail de mémoire
entrepris par emmanuel macron mais aussi
on va parler des jeunes issus de cette
histoire même s'ils ne l'ont pas vécue
ils sont traversés par elle peut être
que vous nous on dirait un move ou
peut-être en circonscription voulait
rencontrer dans dans les écoles si on
vous invite benjamin stora c'est aussi
parce que cet anniversaire et tombe en
pleine campagne présidentielle cette
mémoire on l'entendait encore en
matinales radio elle peut être parfois
un peu instrumentalisée alors on a plein
de questions à vous poser comme les skis
ce sujet de stéphane et des pierres
si on vous invite benjamin stora c'est
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous célébrons le
60e anniversaire des accords d'evian et
le soir même à les viser le général de
gaulle pouvait annoncer aux foules
française la conclusion a vu
l'algérie et que vous avez consacré
votre vie à la mémoire de la guerre
d'algérie
ces huit années de conflit ont façonné
le paysage politique français à l'heure
de la présidentielle près d'un demi
siècle après ce pan de notre histoire
s'invite encore dans le débat je crois
qu emmanuel macron un problème avec
l'histoire de france avec l'histoire de
france il est allé dire en algérie que
nous avions commis des crimes contre
l'humanité il est allé dans un média
anglo saxons dire qu'il voulait
déconstruire l'histoire de france et moi
j'assume tout l'histoire de france il
faut tout assumer il ne faut pas sans
cesse se repentir je suis hostile aux
lois mémorielles je serais favorable à
les abolir benjamin stora vous êtes né à
constantine en 1950 puis à paris vous
êtes devenu historien spécialiste
incontournable de la guerre d'algérie et
documentariste votre histoire familiale
et votre travail d'historien sont
intimement mêlés enfants juifs d'algérie
vous quittez le pays 20 jours avant
l'indépendance dès le début de votre
carrière universitaire vos recherches se
concentrent sur ce que la france appelle
encore les événements il est nécessaire
encore et toujours de regarder cette
histoire en face parce que visiblement
les mémoires continue de saigner à
l'intérieur de la société française par
les différents groupes porteurs de cette
mémoire douloureuse les européens
d'algérie ce qu'on appelle les pieds
noirs bien entendu les soldats les
appelés du contingent près d'un million
et demi d'hommes c'est un groupe énorme
dans la société française mais il ya
aussi bien sûr les troupes supplétives
musulmane on le sait les harkis bien sûr
et puis les immigrés algériens en france
et leurs enfants et petits enfants car
nous en sommes aujourd'hui à la
troisième génération tout naturellement
c'est donc vers vous qu emmanuel macron
se tourne pour ausculter la mémoire de
la colonisation et de la guerre
d'algérie votre rapport paraît début
2021 malgré les dizaines de livres les
témoignages les films par vous et par
d'autres vous estimez que le chantier
pour panser les blessures restent
immenses alors benjamin stora éclairez
nous cette histoire et l
instrumentaliser par les politiques
l'époque doit elle être à la
reconnaissance ou à la repentance
comment réconcilier les peuples français
et algérien
voilà on va répondre on va tenter de
répondre à ces grandes questions mais
benjamin stora partons quand même de
cette date 60 ans jour pour jour 1 18
mars 1962 dans quel état est la france à
ce moment là et qu'est ce qui permet au
fonds d'arriver à la signature de ces
accords à evian les bains qui marque
d'abord le début de la fin du processus
enfin en tout cas de la sortie de guerre
j'avais la date du 18 mars et c'est
d'abord le cessez-le-feu avant tout les
gens ont pas eu le temps de lire les 93
pages des accords d'evian ils ne les ont
pas plus tard d'ailleurs c'est d'abord
le cessez-le-feu et c'est d'abord qu'à
une date très importante pour les
appelait il ya quatre cent mille hommes
présents sur le terrain en algérie c'est
considérable et donc pour les familles
françaises qui ont un oncle un père un
cousin frères en algérie c'est un grand
soulagement donc le 18 19 mars puisque
c'est le lendemain évidemment quand en
vigueur du cessez-le-feu c'est d'abord
pour eux mais pour les européens
d'algérie comme pour les algériens aussi
qui vivent là bas c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose parce que ils ont le
sentiment que les exactions continuent
d'aimer ça continue la guerre continue
c'est très difficile de sortir d'une
guerre de sept ans on sait plus facile
d'y entrer c'est très facile mais il
sortir d'une guerre comme elle atteindra
violents ou le
tout à fait il pourrait atteindre cet
incendie mémorielle enfin mémorielle nom
à l'époque c'est un incendie réel c'est
très difficile il y aura encore la
fusillade de la rue d'isly les massacre
de harkis et puis aussi contre les
algériens musulmans des tirs au mortier
sur les quartiers de ville et que c'est
à 2 à moi et mes après le référendum le
référendum c'est le 3 juillet 1962 est
en fait la fin de la guerre d'algérie on
pourrait dire c'est un fin d'année 62
chf beaucoup beaucoup plus tard si c'est
donc une à la fois une date importante
mais en même temps c'est une date qui
n'a pas été tellement commémorer parce
qu'ils avaient le sentiment chez les
principales populations concernées que
la guerre continue et ne s'était pas
c'était amusant et puis chez les
algériens il y avait des discussions
tout le monde n'était pas d'accord sur
le sur les accords d'evian il y avait en
particulier les gens
partement à ce qu'on a appelé l'armée
des frontières qui pensaient que c'était
un mauvais compromis puisque la face à
conserver la possibilité de continuer
des expériences nucléaires en algérie et
l'exploitation du qatar donc du côté
algérien comme du côté français pendant
très longtemps cette date a pas été
véritablement une date importante elle
est devenue maintenant à cause du cessez
le feu
il fait pas taire tous les traumatismes
ce qui est très frappant même si on va
en parler il ya un gros travail de
mémoire on est sortis de l'oubli et du
silence on sent bien que les blessures
elles sont très très vives on le voit
comment vous expliquer sa soixante ans
après il ya plusieurs explications
possibles moi j'en vois une
principalement c'est que vous savez
l'algérie c'était la france donc c'était
une part de la nation française donc
c'est un département français
départements français cirque la perte de
l'algérie française quelque part c'est
une sorte de crise du nationalisme
français et ça c'est très important le
général de gaulle dans le fond avait
réussi à masquer quelque part cette
crise du nationalisme français par la
magie de son verbe et ses discours
disons à phnom penh des discours qu'on
connaît à montréal mexico et c'est donc
la france avait le sentiment de
poursuivre une grande histoire mais
l'histoire de lempire s'arrêter en 1962
et les français n'avaient pas encore
vraiment conscience et c'est que plus
tard bien plus tard qu'on a commencé à
prendre conscience dans le fond qui
avait une sorte de rétrécissement de la
mission nationale fin du nationalisme et
certains disons ont joué disons sur ce
retour sur ce ressort pardon de retour
en arrière c'est à dire de grandeur
perdue pour réactiver sans cesse cette
mémoire douloureuse combien de morts
algériens la guerre d'algérie des deux
côtés alors c'est raide enfin savez il
ya toujours des discussions à n'en plus
finir sur la question des morts moi je
pense que au total en est entre 400 et
500 mille morts sur huit années de
guerre ce qui est colossal un appliqué à
une population de 10 millions
d'habitants c'est considérable 1 c'est
beaucoup quand même donc c'est une
période très très difficile sans compter
aussi le nombre de morts qui ont eu lieu
en france parce qu'il ya eu des
règlements de comptes entre algériens il
ya aussi eu beaucoup de français qui ont
été tués les attentats de l'oas et c'est
donc c'est quand même l'aspect à la fois
guerre classique mais aussi la guerre
side l'aspect guerre civile guerre
intérieure française c'est une des deux
secondes raison d'explications d'oubli
entre guillemets c'est l'aspect guerre
civile le speaker france l'état organisé
l'oubli après après les accords d'evian
après soixante on va continuer voulait
absolument une sorte d' amnistie mdj
pour pouvoir construire la france a
avancé alors on va voir si on est on est
sortis de cette amnesty l amnésie ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont été faites on
va regarder avant d'engager le dialogue
avec alexis corbière un extrait de votre
documentaire réalisé par georges marc
benamou vous certains d'entre vous ont
peut-être déjà vu sur france 2 cette
semaine il sera d'ailleurs diffusée à la
rentrée prochaine sur lcp une guerre qui
divisa profondément la france qui la
terrorise à l'histoire de deux peuples
déchiré mais lié à jamais c'était la
guerre d'algérie extrait
ce à commencer par le bruit des hélicos
de teu teu teu teu s'en tirer dans tous
les sens et les pales se croiser
cette terreur que j'ai vu en algérie ces
horreurs c'est insupportable pour quoi
faire fla
la majorité de ma famille a été
assassinée c'est des choses très
violente
je ne sais pas à quel moment j'ai pris
conscience que j'avais perdu une jambe
la guerre d'algérie on devrait dire les
guerre d'algérie une guerre entre
nationalistes algériens et l'armée
française bien sûr il parlait de
terroristes nous parlions de patriotes
mais aussi une guerre entre algériens
celle qui opposa deux mouvements
indépendantistes rivaux et l'autre qui
opposa les harkis ces musulmans pro
français au front de libération
nationale algérien
et puis la guerre franco-française qui
commence à alger en juin 58 paras le
grand malentendu
je vous ai compris je vous ai compris
quand vous dites je vous ai compris à
100 200 mille personnes ils comprennent
qu'on les a compris
une guerre qui divisa la france la
terrorise a durant des années et failli
la faire basculer dans le chaos
j'ai longtemps oublié l'algérie il a
valu pas mal d'années pourquoi je vois à
quel point
j'appartenais à cette terre mon souhait
c'est que on puisse aller vers une vraie
réconciliation et que ces deux peuples
puissent vraiment se parler se reparlent
est vraiment voilà donc la bande-annonce
de ce très beau documentaire au fond on
le voit bien la volonté de se reparler
de se réconcilier elle est là on a
l'impression et vous le dites dans vos
livres qu'on est sorti du silence mais
de façon un peu désordonnée
comme si chacune des mémoires s'étaient
exprimés mais sans qu'on puisse au fond
s'approprier un récit historique commun
on n'en est pas là aujourd'hui non on
n'en est pas encore là bien entendu il
ya des conceptions des rapports à cette
histoire à la nation que ça qu'ils sont
pas les mêmes d'une rive à l'autre de la
méditerranée il faudra beaucoup de temps
et un grand travail de pédagogie et
d'histoire précisément pour parvenir à
essayer d'harmoniser des récits c'est
d'ailleurs le sens de mon travail 1
c'était non pas d'essayer de faire un
seul discours définitif et puis d'en
finir avec tout ça mais d'essayer au
contraire de trouver des points
d'accroché mémorielle sur des questions
très particulière par exemple la
question des archives des disparus des
essais nucléaires des cimetières et c
est à partir de chacun des points non
réglés parce que soixante ans après tous
ces points ne sont pas réglés toujours
pas et bien d'avancer pratiquement pour
parvenir ensuite à la suite de ces
travaux pratiques parvenir ensuite
peut-être à l'élaboration d'un discours
plus comme vous allez le dire ce qu'il
faudrait encore faire vous avez commencé
alexis corbière au fond on est sorti du
silence l'état allait organiser l'oubli
pendant des dizaines d'années après 62
mais de façon un peu désordonnée
si bien qu'on se rend bien compte que
cette mémoire là elle est pas du tout
apaisé vous vous le constater sur le
terrain en tant qu'élu oui puis je crois
qu'on constate tous à tel point
cette histoire ce moment d'histoire de
france j'insiste là dessus parce que la
guerre d'algérie et tous ces événements
c'est l'histoire de france
sont encore extrêmement vivant
passionnel à tous points de vue au moins
vous savez je suis un critique de la
vème république elle n'est dans la
guerre d'algérie et on ne comprend ces
institutions leur caractère m'en donnait
concentration de pouvoirs sur un homme
pour débloquer une situation de guerre
civile ça a été dit par un jardin stora
si on comprend par la guerre d'algérie
on comprend pas la vème république etc
on pourrait continuer les sujets
évidemment je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
d'aspects le coeur de la discussion
aujourd'hui c'est la question qui est
posée par certains c'est peut-on vivre
avec des musulmans qui est aussi un
débat sur l'épisode allianz était de la
colonisation et en même temps avait en
projet de faire société commune pourquoi
ça n'a pas marché moi je fais partie
d'une famille intellectuelle qui dit que
le colonialisme ça n'est pas la
république et d'un certain point ça
pouvait pas marcher il ya une lecture
que je vais qualifier pour cette fibre
plus d'extrême-droite qui consiste aussi
à dire finalement on ne peut pas faire
peuple avec des gens de confession
musulmane qui est un débat qui a lieu à
l'heure actuelle manière ainsi que
d'envoyer je pense sur cet aspect on
pourrait continuer évidence est très
présent et concrètement alors après il
ya une immigration du maghreb en général
et en algérie en particulier qui
évidemment une genèse qui continuent à
s'interroger sur que fait-elle l'a
finalement parce que elle est née en
france leurs parents sont nés en france
mais ils ont toujours un sentiment de
relégation relégation sociale etc et qui
essaie de trouver des réponses aussi
dans la manière dont tu cette histoire a
été mené dans cette colonisation a été
fait est elle positive pas positive et c
est évidemment comme ces questions sont
pas réglés sur plan national comment
voulez vous qu'une jeunesse elle cherche
à le faire il ya énormément
d'associations qui s'interroge puis se
trouver toutes les réponses et c'est
encore en éléments comment dirais-je de
bouillonnement et sais pas si vous
écoutez pas ce que je voulais dire un
mot vous me donnez la parole moi je
crois que le mieux aussi c'est donner la
parole à cette jeunesse je veux moi j'ai
envie je ne suis pas année au maghreb je
suis un jeune français qui par ailleurs
il ya cette histoire par un le mon père
est un homme modeste 6 me regarde le
salut qui le grand est le nom de sa vie
cc 24 mois en algérie et je fais partie
de ce point de vue là je suis
typiquement français l'algérie à être
m'a été racontée par un homme qui l'a
vécu comme sous l'uniforme a et cela
parfois quitter sa petite ville de
béziers il est allé là bas et donc je
crois que c'est benjamin stora je vous
avais lu vous dites qu'il ya quoi plus
de 10 millions de gens sans doute en
france qui d'une manière ou d'une autre
sont liés charnellement à vaccins et
par - peut-être sept millions c'était
dimanche à manger salon et puis avec
cette particularité que c'était un
colonialisme sans aucun doute mais qui
n'y pouvait vous êtes des gens dont les
parents les grands-parents sont
intéressants évidemment je pense à ceux
qui sont deux des algériens
d'aujourd'hui mais mais même les pieds
noirs faut comprendre à quel point
c'était un rapport colonial mais en
rapport aussi évidemment extrêmement
profond et c'est une déchirure une
blessure et donc c'est un sujet qui
n'est pas réglé qu'est ce qu'ils disent
il faut les écouter ma compagne a
rencontré quelques jeunes franco
algérien d'ailleurs aussi quelques
quelques plus âgés écoutez
j'ai 23 ans j'ai pas encore vraiment
construit un avis sur le sujet est à mon
avis à mon humble avis il faudrait
passer à autre chose il faut il faudrait
plutôt penser à l'avenir coco passé
faut-il en terminer avec cette histoire
est-ce que ça qu'est-ce que ça qu'est-ce
que ça produit cette histoire mémorial
qu'est ce qu'elle produit est-ce qu'elle
exaspère les tensions au sein de nos
cuves de de la communauté nationale
française comment effacer cette blessure
dans la vérité peut-être c'est la vérité
qui risque qui pourrait apaiser
certaines personnes qui ont encore deux
années encore
voilà dire la vérité c'est intéressant
parce que c'est compliqué et la question
de la vérité quand on parle de mémoire
alors pour un historien c'est peut-être
la quête voilà ultime emmanuel macron il
a fait beaucoup de choses pour trouver
justement les voies de l'apaisement je
vais en citer quelques unes parce que
ouais là ce qui nous regarde ne sont pas
forcément tous au courant il ya eu la
reconnaissance de la responsabilité de
l'état français dans la disparition en
1957 du mathématicien maurice audin dont
on va voir le visage le voilà ensuite il
ya eu la reconnaissance au nom de la
france que l'avocat du fln ali
boumendjel a été torturé et assassiné
par l'armée française il ya eu ensuite
un grand discours sur les harkis ou là
au nom de la france emmanuel macron
à demander pardon il ya eu aussi sous
l'impulsion de benjamin stora
l'ouverture des archives est-ce que ça
alexis corbière vous saluer ce travail
là oui non mais ces sondes et gestes
importants d'ailleurs moi j'ai pris la
parole jeudi a eu une loi qui était
adoptée sur les harkis qui étaient
importantes et c'est ça je pense que
c'est bien emmanuel macron l'a fait j'ai
en face de moi et benjamin stora celui
est
passé non mais je dire c'était un
travail qui a été fait et s'il m'a dit
ce qu'on a fait plus en un an qu'en 60
ans oui parce qu'on n'avait pas fait
grand chose peut-être 60e sans aucun
doute mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
emmanuel macron a acté aussi des choses
qui dans la société avait avancé me
semble-t-il à je veux pas tu en opposant
un monsieur m'a pris mais là tu je veux
pas avoir une politique il le fait parce
que des gens ont porté une mémoire
pendant longtemps moi j'ai connu
benjamin stora comme étant le premier
biographe d'un homme s'appelait messali
hadj que je ne connaissais pas dont je
n'avais jamais entendu parler et faire à
ta base mais c'est important pourquoi
messali hadj ça montrait la complexité
au sein d'une nationalisant légériens de
grands débats qui sont encore
d'actualité et ça c'est passionnant donc
il ya des gens qui ont porté sa justin
lin l'instant parce qu'il est facilement
y en a d'autres mais est il faut aussi
saluer tout ce travail intellectuel qui
doit être aidé encore aujourd'hui moi je
pense qu'à l'université française il n'y
a pas assez de moyens et pour terminer
je reprends squeeze toner c'est une
histoire de france une histoire
française je dis ça pour ceux qui ne
comprendraient pas que l'enjeu c'est pas
parler de l'algérie comme s'ils ont
plaqué l'étranger cette un problème
franco français et tout le monde a bien
compris non mais uniquement
qu'il faut élargir notre histoire de
france c'est à dire si on veut la
raconter je dis ça parce que certains
disent parfois qu'il y aurait des gens
qui voudraient face et porter l'histoire
c'est le nouveau kizuki mais qui sait
qu'il veut effacer l'histoire de france
si ce n'est ceux qui pendant des années
ont empêché qu'on parle de cette
histoire à l'enregistrement comprenant
la france si on ne parle pas de
satisfaire l'enseignement de la guerre
d'algérie à l'école il ya des choses
qu'on peut faire au niveau politique
d'une parole qui engage l'état mais il y
a beaucoup de choses à faire avec la
jeunesse je me souviens sur ce plateau
vous y étiez déjà il y avait une
enseignante qui nous disait au fond la
guerre d'algérie ce pas compliqué c'est
optionnel ont fait l'inde pour parler de
la décolonisation et de la colonisation
ou l'algérie est beaucoup pour
s'épargner des difficultés de
d'enseignants choisissent l'inde c'est
toujours le cas c'est comme ça que ça se
passe non je peux pas rentrer dans tous
les détails mais on a fait énormément de
progrès sur l'enseignement d'histoire de
guerre d'algérie en france faut pas
croire que rien n'est jamais fait on ne
parle jamais de rien et c'est non on ne
vous l'avait dit tout à l'heure on est
sorti du silence à la guerre d'algérie
tombe au baccalauréat de manière
régulière elle tombe dans les concours
etc la vraie question c'est la formation
des maîtres s'il ya des gens qui sont
capables de pouvoir enseigner cette
histoire c'est vrai c'est ça le
véritable label le véritable enjeu c'est
serré c'est la première chose
c'est à dire qu'il ya pas ya très peu
dans les universités pour là pour former
les médias pas y'a pas de suffisamment
de postes par exemple en connaissant
histoire du maghreb contemporain de
l'histoire de la colonisation de la
guerre d'algérie très peu de postes il
faudrait créer je sais pas 20 30 40
postes de professeur d'histoire à
l'université pour pouvoir précisément
transmettre la question de la
transmission de ce savoir et cette
connaissance au collège pardon et au
collège au lycée c'est surtout oui mais
il faut il faut former des maîtres pour
pouvoir transmettre et puis il ya dix
ans un autre aspect c'est que c'est pas
tellement la question de la guerre
d'algérie qui peut enseigner c'est
surtout le problème général de
l'histoire de la colonisation le
problème de l' empire colonial la france
a été un grand empire et la fin de la
guerre a signifié la fin de cet empire
et donc il faut par conséquent aussi
comprendre ce qu'a été la crise la
construction et la crise de cet empire
car tout empire périra le savons c'est à
dire alexis parler de la question du
rookie sme c'est aussi le vous avez vu
forcément qu'il ya un mouvement porté
par certains intellectuels des
journalistes pour effacer ou enlever les
les noms de rues au général bugeaud vous
parler de la colonisation
il faudrait faire cet effort là là je
parle pas de garden je peux le faire
part d'ombré parce que si on enseigne
bugeaud par exemple j'ai entendu qu'un
candidat monsieur zemmour disait moi je
suis aux côtés de bugeaud mais rappelé
que d'horizon général bugeaud qui est
celui qui participe
à la conquête modèle des colonnes
infernales vendéenne d'ailleurs il le
fait très brutalement et violemment
fumades en algérie organisée en 1845
notamment et moi j'ai pris plaisir à
regarder le documentaire de benhamou
histoire c'est que il ya aussi au même
moment victor hugo qui à l'assemblée
nationale dénonce à ce que je veux dire
c'est que l'histoire de la france
l'histoire républicaine c'est à la fois
l'histoire du colonialisme et de voix
républicaines qui sont anti coloniale
c'est ça qui est intéressant pour un
homme comme moi qui suis républicain
c'est que quelque part on ampute pas
notre histoire quand on la rencontre au
contraire on lui donne toute sa grandeur
et de montrer que le colonel était
critique y compris celles avec les
coulisses audrey débaptiser un certain
faut voir oui pour faire débaptiser là
encore est ce qu'on peut pas se dire
aussi qu'on va intégrer des noms
nouveaux qui sont actuellement effacés
oui elle qui commence il ya une
commission là dessus un bus et dans mon
rapport aussi parce que j'ai par exemple
il y avait la stature érigé en l'hommage
de l'émir abdelkader c'était dans mon
rapport qui a été vandalisée par
malheureusement amboise a enfin je peux
pas énumérer toutes les préconisations
dont certaines n'ont toujours pas abouti
comme par exemple celle concernant
gisèle halimi par exemple alors
justement
je pourrais je pense que au panthéon oui
je pense que ça gt s'ils étaient surpris
du refus femmes du refus fin du silence
autour de cette proposition j'étais
surpris parce que je pensais que cette
personnalité
rassembler en elle même par son histoire
et sa trajectoire différents aspects de
cause contemporaine française c'était
revient sur la question coloniale mais
aussi le féminise la lutte sur l'île et
j'ai la question du viol c'est quand
même une personne un personnage
extraordinaire et j'ai été surpris de
voir dans le fond que certains accepté
toujours face à trajectoire dans sa
défense de djamila boupacha avec simone
de beauvoir et ça a provoqué
malheureusement une sorte de silence
espère que ça rebondira autour du gisèle
halimi parce que on parlait tout à
l'heure de l'enseignement de l'école
voilà une figure exemplaire à partir de
laquelle on peut expliquer certains noms
de combat féministe du 20e siècle on a
monté alors ça c'est l'histoire de
france il ya aussi une histoire affaires
en algérie oui et côté algérien alors
est-ce que ça bouge ou pas alors à la
fois ça bouge à la fois c'est difficile
parce que à la fois sa bouche parce
qu'il est évident que il ya encore vingt
trente ans connaissait pas dans les
manuels scolaires algériens les figures
de messali hadj de faire un tabac sur
tous ces grands personnages qui avait
fait la guerre d'indépendance à qui
avait été mis au secret et plus tard
comme hocine ait ahmed et c'est bon ça a
bougé son n'est plus du tout là dedans
en algérie à des choses qui ont été
faites mais en même temps mais en même
temps il y a quand même des fermetures
d'archivés ya quand même des problèmes
disons de non accessibilité à des
savoirs il ya des tas vous encore qui
réalise crispations diplomatiques avec
alger
et clairement
il ya par exemple l'assassinât de leader
algérien comme abane ramdane qui ont été
assassinés pas parler français mais à
l'intérieur du mouvement national cher
et ça ce sont des questions encore tabou
en algérie et qui ont été posées par le
mouvement démocratique durée d'accès sur
le mouvement démocratique algériens qui
ont posé ces questions là les questions
de d'aller vers plus de vérité
d'histoire vous parliez de vérité il
faut s'approcher de la vérité prochaine
la vérité côté algérien est ce que comme
beaucoup d'ailleurs un des deux
candidats à la présidentielle deux
députés vous exhorter les algériens à
ouvrir cette mémoire là vous souvenez
vous souvenez ce qu'avait dit emmanuel
macron alors c'était lors d'un déjeuner
privé il avait parlé de rentrer
mémorielle des algériens est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec lui est ce qu'il ya
un côté rente mémorielle
admettez que c'est piégeux que nos
politiques français disent aux algériens
ce qu'ils doivent faire je trouve qu'il
a il faut être extrêmement tocci comme
on dit aujourd'hui est sensible crois
que le prends la buick a été un peu loin
quand il a même dit que la nation
algérienne n'existait pas avant que les
français arrêtent tout ça c'est des mots
à mon avis qui que les historiens
s'exprime mais je crois qu'on présente
la république c'est dans l'huile
sont ravis mais n'empêche que il a été
dit devant un journaliste et quand on
est prêts viendraient pluie qu'on sait
maintenant mais donc ce que je veux dire
c'est considérer que l'algérie doit
aussi avancé oui non mais moi j'ai
applaudi quand le peuple algérien en
2019 était dans la rue peuple
extrêmement politique il dit des choses
très fortes qui se réclamait d'une
république algérienne qu'ils aient un
seul héros le peuple pendant
constituante oui non mais n'assure la
constitution et que pour une assemblée
constituante moi je suis pour en france
bon jeu mais jure ce peuple que sous on
simplifie d'une autre de l'autre côté de
la rive est un peuple très politique
très dynamique avec une jeunesse qui
veut aujourd'hui en finir avec la
corruption en algérie qui pensent que le
système politique est bloquée et c'est
moi je ne peux qu'applaudir amusé comme
un aveu sa garde et avoir un discours
commun entre les deux présidents 7
millions dh à musique pourquoi je sais
dans mon rapport c'est bien et c'est un
set à l'oeuvre cirque le maire de
montpellier a accepté la proposition a
préempté un terrain il va on va
construire une cité en fait sur le
modèle du mucem on va pouvoir échanger
sur cette histoire ancienne d'un siècle
et demi en invitant des artistes
algériens de faisans des résidences
intellectuelle d'artistes de créateurs
c'est un projet qui est très ambitieux
sur les dix ans qui viennent c'est un
vrai projet extrémités mis en place par
par emmanuel macron où il ya beaucoup de
jeunes notamment avec toutes ces
mémoires que ce soit les rapatrier que
ce soit les combattants qu'est ce qu'il
va faire quelle est sa mission on
parlait de d'un comité vérité et
réconciliation un peu comme ce qui
s'était passé en argentine tout ça c'est
c'est possible là je sais pas exactement
ce qui va se faire selon plein dans la
campagne présidentielle donc je vais pas
anticiper sur ce qu'il pourra se faire
par la suite mais il est évident que la
question centrale c'est la question de
la jeunesse aujourd'hui ça a été évoqué
un palais qui corbières l'instant c'est
à dire de transmettre à savoir une
connaissance je suis pas ni pour effacer
n'est pour ajouter face il faut ajouter
plein d'histoires mais il faut quand
même entrer dans la connaissance de
cette histoire complexe les gens sont
très étonnés à partir de mon rapport de
découvrir que soixante ans plus tard il
y avait des essais nucléaires français
en algérie il y avait des cimetières qui
n'était pas entretenu il y avait des
archives enseveli y avait des disparus
qu'on avait toujours pas retrouvé vous
rendez compte soixante ans plus tard et
à ce moment là effectivement plein de
gens se sont dit mais qu'est ce qu'on a
fait pendant 60 ans est-ce que vous
beaucoup de discours beaucoup de
discours la repentance par la repentance
et que c'était excitant mais il ya des
gens qui cherchent leur disparu il ya
des gens qui cherchent enterrer leurs
morts ce sont des choses très très
concrète retraités on peut pas faire le
travail de deuil d'une histoire si on
n'avance pas sur le plan pratique sur
cette histoire sinon on en reste au
stade des disputes idéologiques étaient
à la culture un dernier mot parce que je
crois c'est dans la gangrène et l'oubli
un de vos livres le fait que quand on
voit les états unis d'amérique il ya eu
énormément de films qui ont été faits
sur des guerres la guerre en corée la
guerre du vietnam etc et que longtemps
le cinéma français qui est un puissant
vecteur de connaissance quand même
populaire etc est resté très silencieux
sharga d'algérie alors depuis moi j'ai
vue magnifique film de lucas belvaux des
hommes qui est très intéressant il y en
a d'autres je pense qu'il faut aider ça
le documentaire vous avez fait est bien
aussi aussi une manière de s'approprier
cette histoire finalement de manière
assez apaisés parce qu'on partage des
choses on et ça permettra que
globalement notre société avant sur une
des réalités alors je veux terminer par
la question présidentielle alors on vous
avait évoqué la date du 18 mars marine
le pen l'a fait aussi elle vous a
interpellé à elle vous accuse d'avoir
une vision un peu militante de la guerre
d'algérie de son histoire on va
l'écouter c'est pas le cas on va
l'écouter puis voulait répondre
benjamin stora n'est pas là pour
réconcilier benjamin stora est là pour
défendre une vision totalement biaisée
de la guerre d'algérie d'ailleurs je
vous signale opposé à cette cérémonie
mais je ne me pose pas mais je conteste
et nous contestons depuis longtemps
cette date choisie parce qu'en réalité
cette date qu'est qui a été imposée
comme la fin de la guerre des jets n'a
pas été la fin de la guerre d'algérie
car il y a eu des dizaines de milliers
de harkis après cette date qui ont été
sauvagement assassinés ça vous l'avez
dit vous êtes d'accord finalement oui on
l'avait lorsqu'il fait poursuivre comme
historien sérieux considère que le 19
mars marque la fin de la guerre dans le
jeu vous avez vous avez vu que
systématiquement des candidats vous site
oui j'ai vu comment vous vivez au bien
et mal joue pas je sais pas j'ai pas
rejeter sa bien évidemment pas autant
dire que c'est biaisé non moi je combats
la mémoire hémiplégique certains noirs
qui regarde que d'un seul côté sert la
souffrance d'un seul groupe de mémoires
moi j'ai essayé de regarder de tous les
côtés et tout mon travail universitaire
depuis eu 40 ans maintenant c'est de
regarder de tous les côtés on a cité la
mémoire de messali mais j'ai écrit aussi
la biographie de françois mitterrand et
du général de gaulle s'est il faut
regarder de tous côtés le grand drame de
marine le pen c'est qu'elle regarde que
d'un seul côté elle a une mémoire
hémiplégique bon je voudrais qu'on
termine ce ce dialogue forcément par
d'une guerre à l'autre
benjamin stora demain à l'elysée on va
célébrer à 60 ans delà des accords
d'evian en pleine guerre onu cren
vadimir poutine qui annexe une
démocratie tournés vers l'europe un pays
entier anéanti sous ces bombardements
c'est incroyable de se dire ça
aujourd'hui c'est incroyable parce qu'il
ya des points bien sûr de différence 1
mais ya des points de concordance qui me
trouble moi bah oui parce qu'on emploie
par exemple 20 poutine emploie le terme
d'opérations de police opérations
spéciales c'est très exactement ce que
disait la france en algérie et 10 n ya
pas de guerre ces sont des événements
d'aviron voulait pas prononcé le mot
guerre c'est extraordinaire et puis
d'autre part il ya une concordance et le
problème de l' empire parce que dans le
fond ce qu'a voulu disons-le a dit mr
poutine c'est de ne pas reconnaître le
droit des peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes
et quand on ne reconnaît pas la
possibilité un peuple d'exister par
lui-même l'empiré menacé et s'effondre
c'est ce qui s'est passé en algérie il
faut qu'il fasse très attention parce
que de son point de vue à lui parce qu'à
force de ne pas reconnaître la volonté
l'aspiration des peuples à
s'autogouverner indépendamment disons
des empires de tous les empires est les
empires disparaissent et rentre en crise
il ya des concordances
l'autre on que dire si ce n'est que tard
sortir d'une guerre c'est très difficile
donc il ne faut jamais d'en déclencher
non mais j'ai et ne pas rajouter à la
guerre autant possible trouver la paix
de montres l'algérie a pas de solution
militaire à tout ça ce n'est qu'une
solution politique il faut qu'on soit
une solution politique évidemment de
10 tout fait mardi mais il faut insister
faut agir le et pour le coup le prix de
la france agit
j'espère que ce sera positif merci
beaucoup merci infiniment benjamin stora
d'être venu en ce 60e anniversaire des
accords d'evian merci à vous vous restez
avec moi alexis corbière parce qu'on va
s'arrêter à présent sur un tout autre
sujet une proposition choc des manuels
macron sur l'éducation le président
candidat propose un pacte aux
enseignants une augmentation de salaire
à la carte en fonction de leur volonté
ou non et bien d'accepter de nouvelles
missions explications et réactions avec
hélène bonduelle
emmanuel macron veut changer de méthode
dans l'éducation nationale et le premier
bouleversement ce sera dans les salaires
pas question de revalorisation globale
on propose un pacte aux enseignants qui
sont en place et leur disent que vous
êtes prêts à changer votre manière de
faire c'est à dire on vous demande de
nouvelles missions on est prêt à les
payer beaucoup mieux à les reconnaître
mieux vraiment le remplacement
systématique des professeurs absents
c'est le suivi plus individualisé des
élèves c'est le temps aussi
d'accompagnement des élèves dans le
périscolaire c'est difficile d'imposer
de nouvelles règles à tout le monde mais
en même temps c'est difficile de dire on
va mieux payé tout le monde y compris
celles et ceux qui sont pas prêts à
davantage s'engager ou à faire plus
d'efforts une sorte de travailler plus
pour gagner plus une prime au mérite ce
matin devant ce lycée parisien la mesure
est diversement appréciée je suis très
déçu par cette proposition c'est
toujours l'idée que en fait on est assez
payé nous on n'est pas assez payé pour
ce qu'on fait déjà donc là il nous
propose toujours de nous augmenter à
condition qu'on travaille plus qu'on
fasse des remplacements donc ce n'est
pas une augmentation de salaire l'idée
de mérite j'y suis favorable parce que
jusqu'à présent nous notre carrière
fonctionne à l'ancienneté il faut être
attentif simplement à ce que
le mérite soit objectif et non pas au
bon vouloir de 2 par exemple de chef
d'établissement la moitié du budget
éducation jeunesse sera consacrée à la
masse salariale autre piste donner plus
d'autonomie aux établissements scolaires
en clair que les directeurs d'écoles
puisse recruter eux mêmes leurs
enseignants à l'image de
l'expérimentation qui doit être lancé à
la rentrée prochaine dans une
cinquantaine d'écoles marseillaise
le candidat macron veut aussi plus de
transparence dans les évaluations
nationales des élèves je souhaite que
nous puissions mettre à disposition des
parents d élèves les résultats toutes
les évaluations certaine que nous avons
lancés durant ce quinquennat mais qui
permettent de voir aussi des résultats
au niveau de la classe au niveau 2 de
l'établissement et de les rendre
publiques pour permettre aussi de voir
quels sont les modes d'accompagnement et
les pratiques pédagogiques qui
permettent d'avoir des meilleurs
résultats une mesure qui irrite ce
représentant syndical
ce dont nous avons besoin c'est de
soutien d'accompagnement de liberté pour
construire ou au mieux pour nos élèves
mais pas d'une prise à témoin
devant devant l'opinion pas une mise en
concurrence avec les familles vraiment
l'école est déjà très largement sous
tension on a besoin d'une confiance
comment mettre en place ces nouvelles
annonces sans se mettre à dos toute la
communauté éducative
une concertation avec les professeurs
les parents les élèves et les élus
locaux pourraient être mises en place en
début de quinquennat
voilà donc il va y avoir beaucoup de
changements a dit emmanuel macron lui
même hier depuis aubervilliers
évidemment si les français lui font
confiance et qu'il est réélu bonsoir
céline calvène merci d'être là vous êtes
député la république en marge des
hauts-de-seine membre de la commission
des affaires culturelles et de
l'éducation et puis à distance avec nous
bonsoir gabriel holard sauvy est ce que
vous êtes là absolument vous êtes
professeur de mathématiques représentant
du snes fsu val de marne et a énormément
de choses aux finalement sans le dire à
travers de tout tout tout ce volet
éducation
comment au fond on entend déjà les les
syndicats on va entendre ce professeur
de mathématiques
vous répondez à un procès qui voulait
déjà fait de remettre en cause de foot
en compte le statut de l'enseignant avec
ce pacte de rémunération au mérite vous
dites vous même qui avez beaucoup de
choses derrière les annonces du candidat
emmanuel macron beaucoup de l'éducation
ça je voulais sur le volet éducation m'a
rien
ce n'est pas rien mais ces armes est
quand même en perspective avec aussi une
idée forte qu'il ya une ambition
éducative et ça on peut dire aussi que
le premier quinquennat en a fait la
démonstration et notamment ou par
rapport à la rémunération des
enseignants alors on part d'assez de
loin on part aussi avec un gel voilà de
lundi ce que l'on souhaite lever parce
que l'un pour tous les fonctionnaires
d'état mark toner est forcément ça ça se
traduit sur les sur les 12 milliards que
le président candidat veut mettre sur la
table pour l'éducation il y en a six
réservées aux rémunérations mais si j'ai
bien compris son projet mais vous êtes
là pour vraiment l'expliquer c'est
sibyllin seront données en fonction des
nouvelles missions accomplies c'est pas
des augmentations on va dire général
alors c'est pas des augmentations
générales mais il y aura quand même avec
l' indice fin le dégel de lundi une
augmentation générale en fait derrière
il ya aussi un préalable c'est celui de
la détermination d'un pacte avec les
enseignants et le pacte avec les
enseignants c'est aussi moi j'y vois une
opportunité
reconnaître que des enseignants
aujourd'hui font plus que ce qu'on leur
demande et on peut aussi le voir moi je
vais vous donner un exemple très concret
il ya quelques semaines j'étais dans un
collège de ma circonscription à
levallois et je voyais qu'il y avait un
tas d'activités qui étaient proposés par
les professeurs eux-mêmes sur la pause
méridienne et qui participe du coup l
attractivité du collège qui fait face à
beaucoup de concurrence de deux collèges
privés autour et bien quand on regardait
comme en été dispatchés les moyens pour
ces activités on se rendait compte que
certains a été pris sur la dotation
horaire globale mais la plupart étaient
du temps bénévole que donnaient les
professeurs au profit du coût de leurs
élèves et comme je vous disais de cette
attractivité du collège monolithe ça
existe déjà en fête est en fait ces
enseignants travaillent plus et ne
gagnent pas plus on sait reconnaître et
et j'imagine qu'elle et qui corbières
est un professeur n'a pas compté les
dizaines de minutes qu'il a pu passer en
conseil de m auprès d'eads et des
parents d'élèves en fait on sait que ça
existe par contre c'est pas forcément
compte et est ce que dans ce pacte
d'enseignants c'est pas aussi le moyen
de reconnaître et de rémunérer ce qui
est fait en plus donc moi j'y vois une
eau pour lavaur assurer à la communauté
enseignante en disant finalement vous
serez augmenter puisque vous travaillez
déjà plus alors que les dés c'est enfin
pour ceux qui se défoncent cus il ya
peut-être aussi derrière ils le font pas
pour ça parce que autrement il ne le
ferait pas dans les conditions actuelles
mais ils le font parce que il ya une
envie soit il ya un goût voilà pour le
théâtre et ont donc on propose un
atelier taylor voilà les missions
l'émision élimine le périscolaire c'est
ça la première démission c'est pallier à
l'absence dé d'être allé faire des
remplacements effectifs faire des
devoirs éventuellement en cours
supplémentaires pour encadrer les ailes
le la chance d'avoir des parents pour
les faibles et les élèves fait déjà
l'objet d'une indemnité on a déjà au
collège parce que moi je trouve que
c'est vraiment collège conte il va
falloir renforcer
l'accompagnement on a deux voire fait
qu'ils étaient parfois fait par des
professeurs mais aussi par d'autres
agents de la communauté éducative aussi
ou des associations ça fait l'objet de
rémunération mais on peut dire qu'on
peut aller plus loin et le périscolaire
c'est une chose le remplacement et le
remplacement effectif que l'on puisse
aussi maximiser le type de personne qui
peuvent remplacer leurs collègues quand
il en connaissait déjà un peu plus clair
on va tout de suite allé voir gabriel
holard sauvy je vous donne la parole
dans un instant professeur de
mathématiques représentant du snes fsu
au val de marne comment vous accueillez
au fond ce pacte que vous propose le
président candidat a déjà quand il nous
dit qu'il nous propose de nous à nous ça
nous fait drôlement rigoler parce que
c'est vrai que ça fait cinq ans qu'on a
déjà affaire à un ministre blanquette et
nitreux blanc qu'elle nous a jamais rien
proposé ils nous imposent les choses en
général la veille la veille au soir
juste à la fin des vacances et en plus
dernièrement depuis les visas donc on a
bien vu que sur le ne serait ce que la
pratique sur la forme sur la discussion
collective bombasse et c'est vraiment
pas des gens qui ne comprennent pas
qu'une consultation si le président est
réélu qui durerait six mois en début de
mandat ça vous rassure ou pas pas
vraiment parce que ça fait cinq ans
qu'on est fréquente déjà nous donc de
croire à leur capacité de consultation
c'est compliqué pour nous on n'a aucune
raison de leur faire confiance alors
qu'ils nous l'ont jamais fait puis
surtout enfin je veux dire on entendait
madame la députée tout à l'heure elle a
commencé par dire ce qu'ils se défoncent
plus ça sous-entend et c'est quand même
très insultant que les autres ne le font
pas je veux dire nous on est des
enseignants nous on a passé un concours
on est à 600 700 kilomètres de chez nous
on a un bac +5 et on est payé entre 1500
et 2000 euros pour travailler dans ces
conditions là dans les pires collège de
du pays ça c'est comme ça on commence
notre carrière de fonctionnaire donc je
veux dire tout de suite on nous dit que
ce qui se défoncent pas ce qu'ils se
défoncent plus comment ça fait ça fait
six ans que je suis là et six ans que
j'attends de pouvoir rentrer chez moi et
que j'attends que mon salaire dépasse de
1000 euros vous voyez bon quand on me
dit que en faisant faire des devoirs
particuliers des cours particuliers à
côté sur le pont du midi et du soir jeu
pour arrondir mes fins de mois mais
s'arrête pas du tout le problème surtout
que moi je suis professeur de
mathématiques il ya une énorme pénurie
professeur de mathématiques elle sera
pas réglé avec des mesures comme ça
qu'est ce qu'on risque d'avoir un
créateur des enseignants de moins en
moins bonne qualité avec des diplômes de
plus en plus on aura n'importe qui en
fait pour faire ce métier vous feriez
j'adore mon école à deux vitesses c'est
ça l'idée bien sûr bien sûr mais c'est
ça qu'ils disent quand ils disent qu'ils
ont recrutés sur profil par rapport aux
chefs d'établissement mais ça veut dire
que du coup déjà qu'on a des déserts
médicaux on aura des déserts éducatif
parce que qui va vouloir faire le
travail là où nous on est dans
l'académie de créteil dans les zones de
montagne dans les campagnes qui va
vouloir faire ce travail mais personne
donc les chefs d'établissement ils vont
recruter personne ou alors ils
recruteront n'importe qui son prix
globalement c'est ça c'est ça que ça
veut dire la fin du statut de
fonctionnaire ça veut dire ça on va on
s'affaire un premier grief vous allez
répondre globalement mais alexis
corbière s'est pas exprimé ce que ce sur
quoi rebondi cet enseignant c'est aussi
le deuxième volet c'est ce qu'on appelle
autonomie du recrutement aux primaires
notamment il ya des expérimentations à
marseille ça veut dire un peu sur le
modèle du privé laisser au chef
d'établissement la possibilité voilà
deux c'est le modèle du privé c'est un
recrutement local en fonction d'un
profil s'est plus au mouvement national
évidemment c'est grave et ça a été dit
moi j'aimerais posent tous les anciens
vous savez un service de 18h vous parle
vous parlez du collège c'est un
enseignant qui travaillent au moins au
moins une heure de conte préparer un
cours 36 heures voire beaucoup plus en
réalité qui sont les enseignants qui se
défoncent pas moi j'en connais pas vous
si vous en connaissez dit le haut alors
appliquant parce que d'évoquer ceux qui
se font plus sans payer mais d'ores et
déjà en raison du gel du point d'indicé
qui existe depuis 10 ans alors les
élections approchent maintenant on parle
de quelque chose qui ne rattrapera pas
par rapport à l'inflation le pouvoir
d'achat des enseignants s'est énormément
dégradé à tel point que du point de vue
de l' ocde tout simplement on a les
enseignants les plus mal payés donc
falloir les bus de début de carrière
donc il s'agissait déjà de rattraper la
perte du pouvoir d'achat unique en leur
demandant graines de plus que j'allais
enfants énormément ce qui a pas le cas
et là c'est pire ce que nous dit en gros
c'est des méthodes qui sont celles du
privé qu'on va introduire dans
l'éducation nationale pour la disloquer
encore plus en mettant en place ce que
j'ai appelé mon locaux d'un débat
séparatisme scolaire encore plus fort il
y aura des stratégies de contournement
des cartes scolaires évidemment ceux qui
auront les moyens ceux qui ont des
stratégies de domiciliation iront dans
les bons établissements on va plus
publié à l'image de ce que font certains
hebdomadaires doha qui existe les bons
résultats des établissements pourquoi
des établissements des bons résultats
parce qu'ils ont les meilleurs élèves
avec les parents qui sont les plus
favorisés et on va creuser comme ça dit
elle en disant plus c'est la faute des
profs silva lui travaille pas bien parce
que les profs sont pas assez motivés
donc c'est évident elle a une bonne
raison d'empêcher ça j'espère que moins
du point de vue des enseignants il y
aura une réaction électorale net c'est
une casse de l'école publique et c'est
très rare je dépends entendu ça depuis
longtemps casse de l'école publique dr
éducatif vous avez dit également que
c'était une école à deux vitesses pour
prendre 3 4 5 6 je voudrais
à répondre aux professeurs qu'on a qu'on
a eu en ligne et oui il ya eu du
dialogue et le grenelle de l'éducation
oui il ya eu de l'augmentation notamment
pour les carrières jeunes enseignants et
ceux qui sont dans les territoires les
plus difficiles en réseau d'éducation
prioritaire donc non enfin il ya eu des
choses de faites et elles n'ont pas été
qu'un poser maintenant aujourd'hui moi
je suis d'accord avec vous lexique et
robert sur quelque chose qui existe déjà
en fait c'est le contournement de la
carte et on l'a bien vu et quand je vous
donner cet exemple de levallois c'est
parce que on est dans nous notre région
est de celles asseoir de la carte
scolaire avec ce nouveau système alors
j'aimerais vraiment dire déjà ce qu'il
en est aujourd'hui et on a effectivement
une concurrence sur des territoires
comme l'ile-de-france hyperdenses
beaucoup plus que dans d'autres
territoires entre l'école privée l'école
publique alors est ce que l'idée c'est
de dire on n'essaye pas de trouver une
amélioration l'amélioration c'est
parfois aussi de donner dans un cadre
national avec la préservation des
programmes des examens nationaux
peut-être aussi une liberté et la
liberté elle n'est pas déterminée
aujourd'hui quand le candidat emmanuel
macron dit voilà moi je vous propose
qu'on aille vers plus de liberté pour
les établissements et qu'on aille vers
davantage d'évaluations et de
transparence c'est pas de dire la
liberté sera totale et on n'aura aucun
cadre national ce n'est pas non plus
l'idée de dire bah on va noter les
meilleurs établissements selon le
résultat des élèves non c'est aussi les
établissements qui sont capables de
prendre des élèves qui ne sont pas
forcément les plus scolairement home et
qu'on arrive justement parce que on les
accompagne pas ce qu'on met en place une
méthodologie 17e caen fait dans ce
nouveau système l'autonomie c'est le
chef d'établissement la rémunération qui
décide que telle ou telle rempli les
nouvelles missions et le pack téhéran je
voudrais que tout n'est pas déterminé
parce que justement ce que veut le le
candidat emmanuel macron c'est que l'on
puisse se poser autour de ce qu est l
ambition pour l'école autour de ses
allées la question de la rémunération la
question de la liberté de
l'établissement et la question ici la
transparence de l'évaluation c'est que
ça ne concerne pas que les parents que
les élèves ou que les enseignants ça
concerne réussi par les collectivités
locales et les citoyens en général qu'on
ait des enfants ou pas et donc qu'est ce
que l'on veut comme de vous redonner un
cadre par exemple la solution elle est
peut-être plus locale tout en respectant
ce cadre national ayant de ça il va
falloir aussi qu'on le conte le
détermine mais où faire du sur mesure en
fait c'est assez je pense que c'est bien
je voulais faire ça existe référence je
vais faire une référence à ce qu'il
existe par exemple dans des pays
européens où je suis allé voir ce qui se
passait en suède et en suède on a un
recrutement national on a une
détermination de grille nationale on a
une formation nationale mais
effectivement et de la même façon qu'on
a pour les attachés territoriaux et bien
la possibilité de pouvoir candidater
auprès des des collectivités locales on
a sept français serait le directeur
d'établissement qui aurait plus de
pouvoirs ces [__] de démobiliser est
un profil je lui le rectorat le
ministère enfin c'est moi l'état qui
file à l'état c'est toujours le garant
et on n'est pas en train de passer d'un
système où aujourd'hui vous aviez un
mouvement national et on serait dans une
libéralisation totale mais par contre de
pouvoir et c'est bien le cas à marseille
de lancer ces expérimentations c'est une
heure mais est ce que ça marche et de
pouvoir le proposer parce que après le
voilà une grande conférence des parties
prenantes on sait très bien que ça va
pas être si le président est réélu ça va
pas être fait à la rentrée 2022 ce sera
plutôt après oui c'est de se dire qu'il
faut mais renchérit parce que le sujet
le sujet nous concerne tout ce qui nous
concerne pas que issimo terminé pour
terminer pendant l'effort bien j'ai pas
bien compris c'est ça marche à marseille
mais quoi non mais tu déjà personne n'y
a rien il ya uniquement en prison qui
est venu nous dire quelque chose de
grave qui a désigné l'ensemble des
questions nationales dans certain c'est
qu'on va découvrir qu'on envoie les
jeunes enseignants pas formés dans les
traditions les plus difficiles bonjour
le scoop je vous l'annonçais d'accord si
on veut faire venir des enseignants plus
expérimentés dans un endroit faut les
rémunérer ce qui est normal d'ailleurs
donc ça d'ores et déjà vous ne le faites
pas c'est à dire que non ça n'est pas le
cas depuis cinquante dates à
responsabilité d donc vous vous avec
cent
mille sept cents aujourd'hui elle peut
être à 2106 aurait plus d'accord donc en
l'espace de trois ans ce chiffre je le
conteste mais surtout d'ores et déjà les
enseignants ils sont évalués vous ne
croyez pas que sont pas évalués et leur
carrière leur avancement et du en
fonction d'une évaluation par ailleurs
on peut imaginer que d'ordinaire dans le
système actuel vous êtes enseignant on
vient vous vous évaluez en classe avec
des inspecteurs qui sont à ça m'est
arrivé quand j'étais enseignant
plusieurs fois qu'il vous donne des
conseils en fonction de la note qui vous
attribuez vous avez évidemment un
avancement de carrière les anciens ils
sont motivés à faire ça mais une fois de
plus je vais donner un chiffre d'une
réalité d'un rapport par le que
l'établissement le moins le mieux doté
de 500 denis est mieux dotée que le
moins bien dotées de paris cette
inégalité est ce qu'on met le paquet moi
j'ai des enseignants depuis la rentrée à
bagnolet qui ne sont pas absents qui ne
sont toujours pas remplacé d'accord
pourquoi parce qu on ne recrute pas ce
travail n'a pas été fait et quelle est
la solution encore plus de disloquer
encore plus des solutions d'allègement
va de toute façon continuer à en parler
beaucoup parce qu'on voit là en découle
ce programme il ya encore beaucoup de de
flou il faut préciser les choses ont
rappelé ce sera exactement en fait ce
n'est pas un programme définitif c'est
une orientation et cette orientation
sociale d'une ambition éducative ont
fait face au problème donc on sait très
bien que mais on essaie de trouver des
solutions associées dans l'éducation
nationale
qu'il faudra travailler allez on va
n'est plus sous entendu vous ne
travaillez pas assez je vous assure que
pour des centaines de milliers
d'enseignants c'est vraiment vu qu
aucune provoque on les a entendus et ce
professeur de mathématiques voilà à
donner une forme de tonalité à mon avis
de ce que représente bien la réaction de
la communauté enseignante merci à vous
on va continuer de parler de ce sujet
c'est sûr ça n'est qu'un début les gens
c'est en cette campagne présidentielle
on va terminer avec ba la page
présidentielle justement en est à 23
jours du premier tour tous les soirs on
passe au crible vous le savez en fait
campagne et ça s'appelle le scam vous
connaissez désormais
mais avant d'être il y a les deux bras
de fatalité au grand remplacement et
bien moi je vous propose le round mort
d'agir pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
travailleuses et travailleurs le système
vous exclus il ya un vrai problème de
pouvoir d'achat rendre à la france sa
grandeur d'arriver à ces repas de
l'histoire c'est le vol
et j'accueille sur ce plateau no3
scanner ses rivaux dell bonsoir merci
d'être là politologue au cevipof
virginis pièce mon soir une petite
nouvelle peut-être sémiologue et vous
allez vous parler de twitter et l'or et
son usage par les par les candidats à la
présidentielle on commence avec le
carnet de campagne de stéphane stéphane
blakowski qu'est ce qui attire et votre
oeil aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui j'ai
décidé de regarder vers le haut c'est
pas parce que lcp est une petite chaîne
qu'on ne peut pas avoir deux grandes
ambitions dont autant frapper fort j'ai
donc décidé d'organiser sur cette chaîne
dans ce studio un débat entre donc
valérie pécresse d'un côté et tenez vous
bien emmanuel macron de l'autre bord eh
ben ce serait une belle affiche mais je
vous rappelle quand même que manuel
macron refusent de débattre ah oui
effectivement ça ça peut ça peut
représenter une difficulté dans
l'organisation de ce débat mais à vrai
dire c'est même pas ce qui m'inquiète le
plus moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est que si
on organise un débat pécresse macron
j'ai peur ça tourne à la foire
d'empoigné j'ai peur que ça soit on se
coupe la parole qu'on se menacent
consensus ne peut être regarder ce qui
s'est passé hier sur france 2 on a voulu
organiser un petit débat janot zemmour
voilà grand ça s'est fini c'est
difficile d'être récit sur 20 ans après
monsieur yves et moi être collabos
aujourd'hui que vous êtes mon
fils c'est vous c'est vrai dit votre
respect et peut-être votre admiration
pour les terroristes qui allieront tués
alice est
venu parler des choix
s'il vous plaît franchement made man ka
wah est ce qu'on a envie de voir ça sur
lcp je vous le demande
non mais c'est normal c'est en direct ça
dérape toujours un peu les débats
présidentiels oui mais c'est ça le
problème pourquoi ça les rapports qu'on
maîtrise pas parce que c'est en direct
donc c'est quand même pas compliqué moi
ce que je vous propose c'est faire un
débat enregistré avec we d'un côté donc
les arguments de valérie pécresse en
vidéo à qui répondraient macron donc si
vous voulez on peut comporter des
erreurs j'ai hâte de voir ça alors c'est
parti on va donc commencer par interrogé
valérie pécresse qui a bien voulu venir
parmi nous et lui demander madame
pécresse que pensez vous de la
proposition de magna macron sur les
retraites en écoute ou alors oui
monsieur macro va faire la réforme des
retraites jusqu'à 65 ans mais qui a eu
le courage de le dire c'est nous
aura-t-il le courage de le faire ça
c'est une autre affaire alors voyez que
le débat démarre très fort le coup est
dur quand même parce que c'est vrai
c'est ce coup de retraite à 65 ans c'est
une idée piquée à la voit donc monsieur
mâcon qu'est ce que vous répondez quand
on vous accuse également d'avoir copié
des idées sur les républicains
je m'en fiche
royalement
totalement présidentielle mans bon
apparemment le candidat mâcon et parle
vraiment déstabiliser très bien n'a pas
balancé tu as vraiment déstabilisés mais
madame pécresse vous avez peut-être
d'autres questions que vous vouliez
parler du nucléaire
pourquoi aujourd'hui nous reparle du
nucléaire qui a reparlé du nucléaire
c'est nous va-t-il le faire c'est une
autre affaire mais vous voyez que ça
cogne fort ce débat parce que la macro
il est dans les cordes qu'est-ce qui
peut répondre il à fermer fessenheim il
veut se faire passer pour un défenseur
du nucléaire monsieur macron votre
adversaire de traite de girouette qu'est
ce que vous répondez
je m'en fiche
royalement
totalement présidentielle m'en voyez
c'était pas mal ce petit débat ça a
permis d'aborder des sujets comme la
transition énergétique la protection
sociale et tout ça sans ce traité ni de
nazis ni de collabo donc je trouve ça un
peu bravache 1 le candidat dans ce débat
macron alors vous avez donné un peu le
mauvais rôle
vous avez trouvez vous aussi qu'il
n'était pas très à l'aise oui alors je
sais pas moi j'ai on verra un peu ce
qu'en pense le public mais en tout cas
pour ce qui est de macron il a peut-être
été un apport ben moi je le donne
gagnant on verra on verra lundi mais moi
il me semble qu'après ce débat valérie
pécresse pourrait encore descendre
peut-être même sous les 10% merci
beaucoup stéphane on enchaîne avec
virginie twitter twitter en période
électorale à quoi ça sert et qu'est ce
que ça donne pour les candidats 28'
rousset 1 c'est le réseau social par
excellence pour les politiques on s'y
exprime gazouille chaque personnalité
politique à son propre compte c'est le
média incontournable des campagnes et de
la campagne actuelle mais quand une
étude ils utilisent twitter en fait les
politiques ne font pas que de la
politique c'est ça qui est intéressant
ils utilisent ce réseau comme une agence
de presse y produit directement de
communiqués de presse des images qui
vont bien l'élément de langage et qu'il
s'agisse du compte des manuels macron le
candidat repas le président bien sûr ou
encore celui d'eric zemmour qui compte
près de 380 mille abonnés ou encore
celui de jean luc mélenchon qui explose
les scores avec de plus de 2 millions
presque deux millions cinq d'abonnés et
bien en fait on propose des discours ont
fait de la com paul et puis on presque
du prêt à réchauffer quoi y'a plus qu'à
mettre au micro ondes pour les médias à
venelles vu qu à vous servir et puis et
puis c'est fait mais en fait ça n'a pas
toujours été comme ça et finalement
c'est assez récent arrêt alors qu'ils
étaient le premier est bien l'enseigné
alors là le premier à voir vraiment
utiliser twitter et en avoir fait un peu
un système c'est il ya dix ans c'était
la campagne de françois hollande
on est en 2012 et son équipe a été la
première à l'époque à tenter des choses
à mettre en oeuvre en fait de nouveaux
dispositifs appelait alors les ripostes
partie lilith des parcs étaient valides
c'était de nourrir les discours c'était
très nouveau c'est exister pas un même
si un système est de faire discuter les
militants sur les réseaux sociaux pour
démultiplier la force communicationnel
en fait donc on avait convié des
militants des gens qui croyaient dans le
dans le projet il se retrouvait sur
twitter et même en vrai parfois dans des
lieux au meeting du bon j'ai par exemple
et puis ils utilisaient les réseaux
sociaux il avait des éléments gage y
avait une bonne ambiance il était assez
libre et puis ça a eu un effet en fait
qui a ambiancé comme dit romain pigenel
qui a été lui le grands organisateurs de
tout cela ça désert ambiance et les
journalistes à leur a donné en fait du
grain à moudre pour au moins deux
raisons parce que c'était nouveau c'est
n'existait pas on pouvait donc raconter
la campagne autrement et ça permettait
d'illustrer quelque chose qui est
vachement difficile à l'illustré dans
les médias c'est le web twitter c'est
difficile de parler de twitter et de le
montrer et d'en parler donc finalement
les ripostes partie elle permettait de
montrer des personnes motivées ont
commandé des pizzas visuellement c'est
est vendeur hollande a les mêmes des
foires souvient d'ailleurs un très bien
ouais on voilà comment les candidats
utiliser tout leur staff pour essayer de
riposter très très vite est-ce que c'est
toujours comme ça qu'on utilise dans
cette campagne 2022 twitter et d'un bon
pas vraiment pas vraiment en fait parce
qu'il s'est passé dix ans et ella
exploratoire c'était ont défriché on
explorait des choses aujourd'hui ben
c'est plutôt institutionnelle en fait on
a peur du bad buzz on tente moins de
choses je suis assez de vous dire que
twitter c'était mieux avant et pas osé
mais presque 1 mais on peut quand même
retenir deux choses c'est que les
réseaux sociaux quels qu'ils soient
aujourd'hui finalement ils permettent
aux candidats de s'exprimer s'adapter à
nouveau discours et de maîtriser un peu
leur communication mais surtout en fait
par rapport à la question du pouvoir de
twitter qu'on interroge souvent moi je
crois plutôt que le vrai pouvoir de
twitter s'il y en a un c'est au pouvoir
de reprise c'est pas ton ce qu'on dit
sur twitter en vérité que l'emea
viralité qui reprennent qui reprennent
et cette circularité en fait aujourd'hui
pour vous répondre pour en terminer
finalement twittait pour les politiques
c'est devenu banal c'est presque devenu
normal comme dirait un ancien candidat à
la présidence
et c'est là un peu et voilà ça lui a pas
fait grande réussite ce président normal
merci donc caisse de résonance plus que
véritable a lieu de bagarres politiques
alors thierry vous avez regardé la
conférence de presse dévoilant programme
du président candidat on en a beaucoup
parlé on a parlé du fond hier on en
parlait encore sur l'éducation il ya un
instant vous départ et de la forme oui
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir de la
forme d'abord ce qui est je crois
impressionnant c'est l'extraordinaire
maîtrise des dossiers des manuels macro
ce qui lui permet d'entrer dans des
détails très technique
sans notes on note aussi une certaine
tendance à la prolixité son introduction
liminaire na a duré pas moins d'une
heure trente et puis aussi des 80 au
total et est aussi un autre trait
fondamental du discours macro niant un
discours très rationnel basé sur la
démonstration l'argumentation est plutôt
que les petites phrases les formules
chocs ou où le recours légaux des
exemples vécus et pris dans la vie
quotidienne en termes savants je dirais
il n y pensais déductive plutôt qu'un
objectif alors c'était intéressant aussi
cette conférence de presse parce qu'elle
marquait le retour à une forme de
communication et on a souvent reproché à
emmanuel macron de ne pas se livrer à
ces à cet exercice de la conférence de
presse et comme s'il voulait esquiver
les journalistes
c'est tout le contraire qui s'est
produit alors tout donc séance de
questions réponses tout à fait longue
séance de 2 degrés de questions réponses
héééé on a souvent reproché à emmanuel
macron petit peu d'avoir un exercice de
la communication parfois juppé thiriat
verticale c'est ça comme s'il voulait
négliger les corps intermédiaires et
comme s'il refusait la critique alors
c'est vrai que c'est pas tout à fait
exact parce que au début du quinquennat
il a été ainsi mais ensuite il a accru
ses contacts avec les journalistes et
avec la presse alors comme on peut
caractériser le temps presse thierry je
vais vous demander de faire un peu plus
court s'il vous plaît notre
communication très rapidement moi ce qui
me frappe c'est d'abord la densité et la
diversité la communication du président
macron nous avons à faire un président
bavard alors que d'autres comme françois
mitterrand avait plutôt tendance
voilà à organiser la rareté de la parole
diversité à travers les formes
l'allocution mais aussi présent sur
facebook mise en scène même d'une
déambulation dans les lisez vous en
souvenez plus sans doute débat marathon
utilisation de multiples retrait
registre de langage un langage parfois
très rationnel et très conceptuel assez
familier je m'en fiche royalement et
présidentielles mans tout à fait à mon
dernier mot alors finalement c'est une
communication très éclectique où on a
parfois de la main du mal à trouver une
direction une logique et à mon avis ça
traduit une détention fondamentale la
communication politique il faut être à
la fois pareil et et différents normal
et transcendant
représenter l'abstrait et puis aussi la
diversité des citoyens et même si macro
et l'apôtre du en même temps il a du mal
merci beaucoup la prochaine fois pour
être sûr d'avoir un peu plus de temps
merci à vous et ses chroniqueurs du
vendredi soir c'est le week-end profitez
bien et à la semaine prochaine il fait
beau
[Musique]